Democrats in the media are melting down
ahead of the Muller report being
released on Thursday
Democratic congressman Steve Cohen
actually using the devastating Notre
Dame fire to attack president Trump take
a look what this president has done and
what he's done to the Constitution
reached under the people's respect for
our government what he has done to the
Constitution and the rule of laws is as
bad as that fire did to no true Dom he's
torching the entire structure of
government and the people's respect for
it he was not exonerated it says Muller
Muller knows more about that the bar bar
was a hitman bar was a hit man hired to
do his job he's doing his job and the
liberal media lashing out at President
Trump and claiming AG bill Barr is
behind some sort of cover-up he's
panicking there that's a like it's a
laughable freak out in Donald part
Donald Trump's party he he's just
spitting out everything he can a lot of
people are on spring break Congress is
on recess they're putting this this
release as late as possible before
Easter weekend when they might get the
least amount of attention now you got to
wonder why he's doing all of this why
he's doing it now is it because he's got
reason to fear what's coming Barr wants
to use this process to try to play down
the report heading into a Friday holiday
weekend rather than play it up
well one of the reasons we wanted to get
out of New York City and out of the
studios to find out when other people
across the country in the heartland are
talking about and it's not about the
Muller report Greg no they're talking
about your hair if your hair got any
higher it would have its own altitude
know what's going on but you know what
the funny thing is
okay this molar freak out is because I
guess some reports coming out on
Thursday it's like the media they're
like drug addicts who found out there's
a new cheaper drug on the street and
they're getting the cravings they got
the molar craving they should just quit
cold turkey the problem is they can't
quit cold turkey because they sold their
audience of bill of goods they made it
sound like they they made the molar
report into the game of Thrones right
but it turns out it's going to be like
Bobby Ewing's dream you know wake up
nothing's gonna be there and what are
they gonna tell their hammer their
viewers which are hemorrhaging cnn's
losing viewers because they lied to them
about this yeah it looks like the
audience's of CNN and MSNBC are hooked
on fakes news as Greg said they need
their fix and they have to hear
scandalous conspiratorial reports or
they're not gonna watch I think well why
you get the hyperbole right so you have
the comparison to the burning of know
true dom which was a felt worldwide it
was like a gut punch for people watching
that beautiful building the the place
where so many religious experiences have
been held over the years including by
young people who are sitting right here
so obviously it just gets to be a little
bit over the top and the thing is if you
cry wolf that many times and then
there's nothing then you don't have
anything to run on no i think everybody
wants to see it you look this this
coming friday i have nothing to do i
don't have to cook i ate this remarkable
chicken here in nashville i'm on a crash
diet so i have the munchies and I'm
waiting for the Muller report see 420
members of contract the molar munchies
and I want to read it I want to repay JH
by page I hope this pitch isn't agree
because it is I'll read it faster maybe
some liquor
I'll read it quicker oh [ __ ] my
Nashville I'm hanging out with you guys
all day so I know what to expect
no but I'm seriously this I'm glad it's
coming out I'm glad we get an
opportunity to look at it I'm glad we
get an opportunity to finally say once
and for all the country was under attack
we know what happened in 2016 and
perhaps we can learn from the mistakes
of 2016 and don't let him get repeated
in 2020 dunno what happened in 2016
Trump won
[Applause]
Johnna Trump to win the question yeah
hold on let's get the job I want to get
to John cuz you know I'm enjoying him
and he doesn't have to wear a hat to
cover all of that hey I want to see it
because I do believe at the end of the
day we as Americans must understand how
to defend our country from future fight
cyber attacks that's it
brother John Oh case ma'am take it away
I think that that is not what your
average everyday American cares about
that's what I think
I think they care about what their tax
rate is I think they care about did they
get their job back or keep the job they
had and if they did do their wages go up
that's what I think you go back to the
Bernie Sanders piece how he sold all
these books how do you think people had
money to buy all his books they got
their tax that's what happened and so
you know I grew up in a double-wide
trailer in Texas nothing fancy and I see
all this stuff going on and I know
that's how the multitude of Americans
actually feel they don't care about this
report this is just a media thing that
none of us really care about on this
thing you keep your hair in a
double-wide trailer my hairs about as
high as Colorado
how are the hair closer to God yeah
that's right that's the cost but it's
all legally your hair yes all legal
that's all that's all legal not edible
though I think we should let a good
Nashville girl run their fingers through
your hair for this show is over with
come on down I think that violates some
Human Resources law getting sued not
Nashville well I here's what I think
that this report when it comes out on
Thursday you will have breathless
reporting that just remember like take a
moment I just find him very hard to
believe that bill Barr the new Attorney
General who has this amazing track
record in Washington DC came out and
said there's no collusion and basically
nothing on obstruction I find it very
hard to believe that he wasn't being
truthful and so now the media has built
it up that he was a liar I find that I
think that they're gonna have egg on
their face again all right Donna whip
the egg off and the break all right